when central banks raise interest rates
it's big news bank is judging that the
only way they can try to pull down
inflation is to carry on raising
interest rates we're going to see rising
rates rising interest rates that will
make the cost to borrowing go up it can
send ripples across the whole economy
it can sink consumer confidence result
in fewer jobs and lower wages and cause
stock prices to fall if they go too far
too fast it can tip economies into
recession
so
why do central banks raise interest
rates
[Music]
let's start with the basics
if you borrow money you'll have to pay
back a little extra to make it
worthwhile for the lender well i think
we can make you this long you have a
good reputation we know you're reliable
i'm glad you think so
this is the interest rate
so if you are taking out a loan you want
the interest rate to be as low as
possible so you don't have to pay that
much back
on the flip side if you want to save
money then a high interest rate means
you can earn more on your savings
see it as a reward for leaving money in
your account but the size of your reward
depends on the circumstances
there's no single interest rate in the
economy you've got thousands of banks
setting their own commercial rates
that's all influenced though by the
interest rate that the central bank sets
a central bank is like a bank for banks
just like you and your savings account
banks also earn interest when they leave
money with a central bank
commercial banks have these things
called reserves so that's a bit like
their cash on hand
commercial banks lend those excess
reserves to each other at an interest
rate and they also can deposit their
excess reserves at the central bank
and when they do that they can earn an
interest rate
ordinary people can't access the
interest rate on the excess reserves but
it still affects them
and that's the idea
when central banks raise interest rates
they're trying to control inflation how
fast prices rise for everyone they were
129 now they won 39 and last in the
space of four weeks central banks like
the fed or the bank of england or the
european central bank are all trying to
hit an inflation target of two percent
interest rates are a really powerful
tool that they have to do that
if inflation is seen as too high
that's when banks raise interest rates
the change spreads through the financial
system and slows down the rate of
inflation
here's how
a rise in interest rates from a central
bank means that a commercial bank will
earn more on their reserves
they might make more from keeping their
money in a central bank then lending it
out
so if they do lend it out they'll raise
their interest rates to make it worth
their while
how that affects consumers depends on
the economy
take mortgages
in places like finland or australia
lots of people have mortgages with
variable interest rates
if you've got a variable rate mortgage
where the interest rate that you pay is
linked to the central bank's interest
rate then higher interest rates mean
that essentially immediately the higher
rate will translate into less cash to
spend on other things
less spare cash means households will
spend less
and less spending means businesses will
be warier of raising prices this should
lower inflation
in other countries like america or
canada a bigger share of mortgages are
set at fixed rates
people with fixed rates are protected
against the direct effects of an
interest rate rise
but will still feel an indirect impact
higher interest rates mean that
mortgages will become more expensive
if that is affecting all new buyers then
house prices will begin to fall and that
will make everyone who owns a home feel
poorer and therefore they might spend
less
lower spending will translate into lower
inflation
and it's not just consumers who will
tighten the purse strings
when interest rates rise then businesses
will find it more expensive to borrow
and invest
that generally means less economic
activity it might mean fewer jobs are
created
fewer jobs and lower wages could mean
less money for households and consumer
confidence might suffer which also means
less spending
people are grappling with a decline in
real wages meaning their money buys less
when interest rates rise that will tend
to slow down spending investment and
generally depress economic activity
overall that will make businesses more
reluctant to raise their prices
and that will tend to pull back
inflation
it sounds straightforward right
but the trick is judging how far to go
in 1981 the federal reserve america's
central bank allowed interest rates to
rise to a whopping 19
the move curbed inflation but it led to
widespread economic pain
i regret to say
that we're in the worst economic mess
since the great depression
it is very difficult to get inflation
under control
without severely denting economic
activity in america it's been over 70
years since they've managed to get
inflation down from over five percent
without causing a recession
a little inflation is okay it keeps the
economy moving at a sensible speed but
inflation staying high for too long is a
problem
higher prices means employees will need
higher wages pushing up costs for
businesses that could drive up prices
further potentially leading to an upward
spiral of wages and prices
retail inflation india has surged to 7.8
percent the combination of step 8
economic activity and high inflation
poses serious challenges for indian
economy going forward central bankers
are really concerned about setting
expectations of inflation the idea is
that if it can show that it is credible
that it will always act to get inflation
back down to two percent then maybe it
won't have to you know raise interest
rates and then lower them in this kind
of seesaw fashion
raising interest rates can slow an
economy right down the trouble is the
brake pedal has a delay
it can take as long as two years to see
the full results from interest rate
changes
central banks know this
so when they set interest rates they're
actually trying to read the road ahead
but predicting the future isn't easy
the problem is it's difficult for the
central bank to work out whether the
inflation will fall back on its own and
even when central banks do get it right
they might still cause a crash
it may be a blunt instrument
but raising interest rates is still
central bank's main tool for taming
inflation
central bankers would say that yes
raising interest rates can be painful
slowing down the economy is not fun
but it's worth it it's worth it to get
low and steady inflation so that in the
long run you don't have to think about
it
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage on interest rates click the
link and don't forget to subscribe
you